Logistic regression predicts
the probability of the outcome
variable being true.
In this example, a
logistic regression model
would predict the
probability that the patient
is receiving poor care.
Or if we denote the
PoorCare variable
by y, the probability
that y = 1.
For the remainder
of this lecture,
we will denote poor care by
1, and good care by zero.
So, since the outcome
is either 0 or 1,
this means that the probability
that the outcome variable is 0
is just 1 minus the probability
that the outcome variable is 1.
So by predicting the
probability that y = 1,
we also get the
probability that y = 0.
Just like in linear
regression, we
have a set of independent
variables, x1 through xk,
where k is the total number of
independent variables we have.
Then to predict the
probability that y = 1,
we use what's called the
Logistic Response Function.
This seems like a complicated,
nonlinear equation,
but you can see the
familiar linear regression
equation in this Logistic
Response Function.
The Logistic
Response Function is
used to produce a
number between 0 and 1.
Let's understand this
function a little better.
This plot shows the
logistic response function
for different values of the
linear regression piece.
The logistic response
function always
takes values between 0
and 1, which makes sense,
since it equals a probability.
A positive coefficient
value for a variable
increases the linear
regression piece,
which increases the
probability that y = 1,
or increases the
probability of poor care.
On the other hand, a
negative coefficient value
for a variable decreases
the linear regression piece,
which in turn decreases
the probability that y = 1,
or increases the
probability of good care.
The coefficients, or
betas, are selected
to predict a high probability
for the actual poor care cases,
and to predict a low probability
for the actual good care cases.
Another useful way to think
about the logistic response
function is in terms of
Odds, like in gambling.
The Odds are the
probability of 1
divided by the probability of 0.
The Odds are greater than 1 if 1
is more likely, and less than 1
if 0 is more likely.
The Odds are equal to 1 if the
outcomes are equally likely.
If you substitute the
Logistic Response Function
for the probabilities
in the Odds
equation on the
previous slide, you
can see that the Odds
are equal to "e" raised
to the power of the linear
regression equation.
By taking the log of both
sides, the log(Odds),
or what we call the
Logit, looks exactly
like the linear
regression equation.
This helps us understand how the
coefficients, or betas, affect
our prediction of
the probability.
A positive beta value
increases the Logit,
which in turn increases
the Odds of 1.
A negative beta value
decreases the Logit,
which in turn, decreases
the Odds of one.
In the next video, we'll build a
logistic regression model in R,
and predict the quality of care.